und wir machen weiter hierbei bild leib
mit ganz aktuellen bildern die uns aus
kabul erreichen jagdszenen auf den
straßen der afghanischen hauptstadt wir
sehen hier die geballte brutalität der
taliban mit denen sie eine frauen
demonstration auflösen mit stöcken
bewaffnet verfolgen sie die frauen und
schlagen dann gnadenlos auf sie ein
wir schalten live nach kabul zu unserem
reporter paul ronzheimer paul du hast
diese bilder gedreht erzählt uns was du
erlebt hast
mein kameramann jorgos motiv ist und ich
waren heute auf dem weg zu dieser frauen
demonstration dort wurden wir erst mal
von den taliban angegangen journalisten
wurde verboten dort zu filmen einige
wurden sogar festgenommen dann wurden
handys zertrümmert und dann haben wir
aus einem versteck sozusagen szenen
filmen können die einen an das
mittelalter erinnern muss man sagen wir
haben diese frauen erst dort die straße
lang laufen sehen hinter ihnen ein
militärfahrzeug der taliban dann wurden
sie von kämpfern gestoppt und dann hat
er den stock rausgeholt und ist hinter
diesen frauen her und dabei haben sie
nur freiheit freiheit gerufen das war
das einzige verbrechen das die frauen
begangen haben aber man muss eins sagen
thomas unglaublich mutig das überhaupt
rausgegangen sind schon gestern wurden
frauen hier auf den straßen angegriffen
und man muss eines klar sagen die
stimmung hier in kabul verändert sich
und nicht zum positiven paul es ist ganz
erstaunlich dass die ganze opposition
nur von den frauen zu kommen scheint sie
sind wirklich die mutige die gegen die
taliban auftreten
die frauen sind auch die die am meisten
zu verlieren haben thomas das sind die
die hier in den vergangenen 20 jahren
für ihre rechte gekämpft haben dafür
dass in die schule gehen dürfen in die
universität dafür dass sie arbeiten
dürfen und sie haben angst dass ihnen
jetzt alles genommen wird und diese
frauen das ist vielleicht auch ein
falsches denken im westen die konnten
eben nicht alle flüchten viele sind hier
wie in einem gefängnis und sind jetzt
diesen taliban ausgeliefert und da gibt
es dann in den sozialen medien gruppen
die hin und her schreiben wir treffen
uns dort wir treffen uns dort dass es so
eine art flashmob demonstration fast und
die taliban sind völlig überforderte
diejenigen die hier die checkpoints
bewachen die haben solche frauen in
ihrem leben noch nie gesehen die haben
in den dörfern gekämpft gegen uns gegen
die internationalen truppen aber eine
frauen demonstration so was sehen sie
zum ersten mal und deswegen auch dieser
brutale einsatz dort von steckern und
die taliban muss man sagen sind nervös
sie haben angst dass ihnen hier die
kontrolle weiter entgleitet konntest du
denn schon mit einigen dieser mutigen
frauen sprechen was erzählen sie dir
die frauen sagen mir wir hören nicht auf
wir gehen für unsere freiheit weiter auf
die straße wir lassen uns von niemandem
den mund verbieten auch nicht von den
taliban
mir ist das sehr sehr nahe gegangen was
ich da heute gesehen habe auf der straße
barbarische szenen mittelalterszene und
ich habe die große sorge dass viele von
diesen frauen verschwinden werden in den
gefängnissen dass sie möglicherweise
getötet werden denn diese brutalität mit
denen die taliban da gegen sie vorgehen
das zeigt dass ich jeden protest im keim
ersticken wollen wir sehen auch bilder
von aus gepeitschten frauen dort und
wenn ich mir die szenen auf der straße
anschauen powell fällt natürlich auch
niemand geht dazwischen niemand hilft
ihnen
nein niemand gibt dazwischen weil die
polizei das sind die taliban
diejenigen die die straßen kontrollieren
das ist das recht das ist das recht
jetzt von den taliban umgesetzt und sie
halten das für völlig normal
gestern hat der sprecher der taliban den
ich ja interviewen durfte vor ein paar
tagen gesagt diese demonstrationen sind
illegal er hat behauptet sie werden von
ausländern hier initiiert worden und hat
auch die presse gewandt mehrere
journalisten sind festgenommen worden
heute ein kollege wurde schwer
geschlagen man hat die merkmale damen
rücken gesehen von ihm de hat er
gekostet also es wird niemand dazwischen
gehen die frauen sind hilflos und die
presse wie wir wir müssen uns verstecken
wir konnten heute nur sozusagen geheim
von einer terrasse das film denn thomas
wenn die taliban uns gesehen hätten dann
werden sie auf uns zugerannt hätten uns
geschlagen hätten uns die kamera
weggenommen und wahrscheinlich
weggesperrt aber paul da stellt sich
natürlich auch die berechtigte frage wo
sind denn die männer auch die ehemänner
dieser frauen
[Musik]
es gab gestern männer die mit
demonstriert haben diese demo die wir
dort gesehen haben war speziell eine
frauen demonstration wo es um die rechte
der frauen geht aber natürlich hast du
recht man würde sich wünschen dass
männer hier diese frauen beschützen aber
sie wissen dass auch sie natürlich von
den taliban angegriffen würden und weist
wie viele waffen die taliban erobert
haben in den vergangenen monaten ist hat
niemand eine chance hier jeder protest
wird von den taliban im keim erstickt
weil du hast gesagt du hast ein
interview mit dem taliban-sprecher
geführt es schien alles sehr konziliant
zu sein man schien bemüht um eine gute
beziehung zum westen auch weil man
natürlich das geld braucht jetzt ist die
regierung die ersten minister sind
benannt worden wie viele bekannte
terroristen sind darunter
also die große frage ist wer hat dort
keine vergangenheit eine vergangenheit
mit denen anschläge gegen deutschland
geplant wurden die deutsche botschaft
zum beispiel da wird vermutet dass das
der harnik klar war und unter anderem
ein herr hakkani soll jetzt
innenminister werden der unter anderem
auf der liste des fbi steht bis zu zehn
millionen dollar sind darauf ausgesetzt
ihn zu finden jetzt weiß man wo er ist
hier auf einen ministerposten und die
europäische union und alle westlichen
länder haben auf diese regierung
einigermaßen fassungslos
reagiert denn sie haben gesagt es müsse
eine inklusive regierung sein das war
der satz unseres außenministers und die
taliban scheren sich einen dreck darum
was der westen sagt sie haben eine
taliban regierung geformt da ist niemand
drin der hier in der vergangenheit eine
rolle gespielt hat da ist keine frau
dabei und da sind auch die verschiedenen
clans sozusagen da sind die
verschiedenen stämme nicht wirklich
berücksichtigt die frage ist jetzt macht
der westen den geldhahn zu oder hat der
westen zu viel angst dass hier noch
deutsche staatsbürger in afghanistan
sind dass dort ortskräfte sind die dann
von den taliban als geiseln genommen
werden könnten das heißt alles was man
vermutet hat dass es tatsächlich leere
versprechungen sind und sich gar nichts
ändern wird scheint genauso einzutreffen
es sieht ein bisschen so aus als seien
die versprechen größer und die aussagen
in den pressekonferenzen größer als das
was dann am ende getan wird man muss
auch so sagen es gibt die eine seite und
die andere seite da gibt es diejenigen
die mit dem westen sprechen wollen und
dann diejenigen die einen härteren kurs
wollen aber fest steht es wird eine ganz
ganz schwierige zeit hierfür die frauen
für die menschen in afghanistan sind
denn das was da von der regierung kommt
das lässt nichts gutes erwarten paul du
hast gesagt das wird auch auf
journalisten jagd gemacht für die
situation auch für euch wird
gefährlicher am anfang schien es ja noch
einigermaßen möglich zu sein auch euch
gegenüber haben die taliban sicher
zunächst konziliant gezeigt auch die
gespräche gesucht natürlich um
aufmerksamkeit zu haben wie geht ihr
jetzt weiter vor
wir werden weiter berichten wir
versuchen alles möglich zu machen das zu
tun damit unsere zuschauer sehen was
hier auf den straßen passiert thomas
heute war es so wenn wir dort auf der
straße gestanden hätten und direkt
gefilmt hätten dann wären wir sicherlich
jetzt heute hier nicht sondern in einem
gefängnis und müssten wieder frei kommen
man muss dazu sagen die internationalen
journalisten die auch gestern
festgenommen wurden wurden dann nach ein
paar stunden wieder entlassen teilweise
wurden aber ihre kameras dabehalten
deswegen man muss vorsichtig sein wir
haben uns dafür entschieden heute denn
als wir dort dann weg getrieben wurden
auf ein dach zu gehen und in einer
geheimen positionen sozusagen weiter zu
filmen man muss kreativ sein um hier in
afghanistan arbeiten zu können dann
bleibt bitte kreativ und passt gut auf
euch auf vielen dank paul
[Musik]